Elon Musk making a shocking announcement
to the world his company neuralink has
installed its very first brain chip in
the head of a human patient no word yet
on who the subject is or if the device
is working but if musk is successful the
tech could be the dawn of a new era for
Humanity a person could control a phone
or computer just by thinking paralyzed
people could start walking and the blind
could start seeing
again all right Jesse the idea of
neuralink helping people with
disabilities is amazing but at the same
time the scary part is can they turn you
on and off like a robot would you be
would you accept that I hope they can
turn me on
Judge hit a switch and there I go I want
this for the Blind and the handicapped
and people with disabilities don't I
ever but it's going to be used by
regular healthy people to turn into
cyborgs and I'm getting a lot of fouchy
vibes with this this is a mad
scientist judge I go into a plane they
make me turn my phone off during takeoff
and Landing but how did Elon Musk get
permission to put a phone in someone's
head this is way way too much we are
going way way too fast this is not
connecting to the internet or technology
this is disconnecting from Life on
planet Earth I like life on planet Earth
things have gone well for me here I'm
going to continue to live outside in
environment instead of sitting in my
cubicle with some machine strap to my
face taking orders from Dr X all right
Dana you know when the rri brothers uh
discovered the the airplane and they
they were called devilish
interventionist or something probably
would have been that person yeah and and
and the thinking was if God wanted
people to fly he would have given them
wings I mean are we just not
understanding this or it was like when
they invented the bicycle they uh they
were upset for the horses and then the
cars they try to stop cars and like you
can't stop progress progress like this
is pretty incredible um a leap like this
could spur gigantic advancement for all
sorts of different Technologies and it I
agree that it feels like things are
moving super fast you know the AI pieces
that we talked about 5 to 10 years from
now are actually more like two years
away now so the advancements are
important I do think that there are
there's more good than bad that could
come of it and for people like I know
that all of us have friends that would
benefit from something like this uh to
either prolong their life or make their
life better while they're here yeah
there's no question Greg that you know
if you have an illness whether it's
Alzheimer's or some of the other
illnesses this can help but they're also
talking about lithium batteries in them
that's exciting you know uh they said
they put it in a human brain so I guess
that eliminates the
squad you know when you talk technology
it's like listening to a clam talk about
stock tips you know okay this is how a
billionaire should act in life look at
the three areas that affect the world
space energy and health and he's
directing all his efforts to create a
better world in the most vital Arenas
now compare that to other billionaires
the Soros family whose billions go to
local laws that have systematically
destroyed cities primarily my minority
neighborhoods I think it's it's a really
interesting and fun time to be alive
when the world's richest man is also the
the world's most helpful man speech
space neurological function energy I
mean these are all facets that directly
affect our lives and that's all and he's
got money to burn I mean he could be
doing other things you know he's not
he's doing this I don't own any stock
I've never you know I've never bought a
stock in my life you're an idiot I know
but I have a great
401K that's
great but I mean you know he's on the
he's on the cusp of a robotic Revolution
too this is going to be I still like the
80s much better Jessica your thoughts I
find it really exciting I don't
understand it and I'm completely
comfortable with that that
I I I hope when it becomes a thing that
I'll start to get it more and we can
really grasp the extent of which this
can create positive change and also pay
attention obviously to the scarier stuff
that could happen but I love stories
about Elon Musk like this I think this
is what he was destined to do and to
change the world and it doesn't you know
change whatever I think about what x has
turned into but I'm excited for this all
right choose Soros or musk you have to
choose choose one now three fast two
what do you mean to do what to like have
billionaire better they're completely
different come on play all right coming
up Jimmy faila taking on liberals who
hate to laugh in his brand new book on
cancel culture he's joining us next hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else